[Musique]
pour moi c'est une élection et qui est
et cède du terrain ciment
supplémentaires après la suppression du
cumul des mandats
parce que les électeurs sont choisis par
un parti politique et et donc ne sont
députés que ceux qui sont en bonne
position sur les listes selon le format
qui ont été choisis format nationale ou
format régionales ou format
départementales en particulier pour les
plus grands départs contre france si
j'ai bien compris le projet de réforme
nouvelle par les alliés de dvd de macron
mais en tout cas c'est pas l'élection du
mérite
la proportion annoncé l'élection de de
ceux qui n'ont pour seul mérite que
d'être bien avec les dirigeants d'un
parti politique que l'on dise qu'il soit
ensuite représentatif de la population
cette amo naji assez formel je crois que
c'est en tout cas un pas de plus vers la
phase mans où le délitement de nos
institutions délitement qui a déjà été
engagée à mon sens avec la réforme du
quinquennat qui a aligné les dommages
aux rites et la majorité présidentielle
et la majorité parlementaire
à tel point que les députés qui sont
élues après président a public sont
évidemment majoritairement du côté du
président d'art public l'évolution et
doit être vert justement des députés qui
sont pleinement attaché au travail
législatif pleinement très attaché au
contrôle du gouvernement et qui doivent
avoir un lien avec le territoire
évidemment tout le monde habite quelque
part il faudrait pas qu'on ait une
proportionnelle intégrale avec une
circonscription nationale on risquerait
d'avoir que des députés parisiens mais à
mon avis il y a des possibilités avec
une dose de proportionnelle ce qui était
proposé d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron
c'est à dire garder un semblant de
députés élus dans des circonscriptions
et puis une dose de proportionnelle ou
bien à voir ce qui se passe avec le
sénat et je pense que personne ne remet
en cause la légitimité des sénateurs
avec des départements où il ya un nombre
important de sénateurs élus à la
proportionnelle
puis des départements où il ya moins de
sénateurs élus au scrutin majoritaire
ça me semble au contraire aller dans le
sens de l'histoire qui n'est pas un
délitement des institutions mais au
contraire une clarification à une
meilleure représentativité des citoyens
le rôle des alliances que nous avons
formé avec le scrutin majoritaire mais
que nous pourrions beaucoup plus
facilement former peut-être beaucoup
plus largement formée avec un scrutin
proportionnel
c'est aussi d'avoir des alliés qui
rappellent des contrats de coalition moi
je vois comment fonctionne la démocratie
allemande avec la chancelière merkel qui
a un niveau de popularité
aucun président de la république depuis
trente ou quarante ans a eu l acquis à
une majorité solide qui réélu à chaque
fois qu'il ya au début de la mandature
des contrats de coalition qui sont
écrits qui sont ensuite envoyés aux élus
locaux aux militants approuvé par la
base et qui sont ensuite suivis et si un
des points du contrat de coalition n'ait
pas suivi à ce moment là le ou les
partenaires peuvent rappeler au parti
majoritaire se saison engagement de
campagne
je pense que ça ça renouvelle la
démocratie l'un des avatars
régulièrement évoquée à l'occasion de
proportionnelle c'est l'instabilité des
majorités où la confusion des genres
nous avons par exemple en allemagne des
majorités qui sont constituées depuis
plusieurs années sous la houlette vannes
merkel avec la recherche sans cesse de
consensus de points d' équilibre qui
érode la vertu du choc démocratique
on a souvent tendance en france à 10 ans
ce personnage cet homme politique cette
femme politique est clivant ou qu'il
vente
mais l'image c'est l'essence même de la
démocratie sans antagonistes n'ya pas de
démocratie c'est la pensée unique ce que
l'on reproche d'ailleurs bien souvent à
un certain nombre de médias qui semblent
exprimer
[Musique]
ce n'est pas un hasard si le maquereau
ou du moins ses amis lui rappelle sa
promesse de campagne alors que nous
sommes quinze mois ou 18 mois de la
prochaine élection présidentielle ça
veut dire qu'un président a besoin d'une
majorité que avec la proportionnelle il
n'est pas sûr d'avoir la proportionnelle
n'est jamais que le scrutin de ce qu'ils
font des calculs et en particulier qui
parient sur le consensus mou c'est à
dire sur le consensus de ceux qui ne
veulent rien changer dans un pays qui
pourtant comme le nôtre est fracturée où
l'état fait preuve de ses impuissances
dans tous les domaines depuis des années
des années on a pratiqué sur ces sujets
qui fâchent un consensus mou et un
consensus mou qui serait inévitablement
porter par une chope de députés qui
seraient élus à la proportionnelle
le modem qui aujourd'hui à un groupe
d'une soixantaine de députés avaient
sous la précédente mandature un ou deux
députés
le front national est très largement se
représenter les écologistes qui
représente un courant de pensée
importants ont aussi des difficultés à
se faire entendre à l'assemblée
nationale et moi je préfère qu'on
débatte qu'on ait un clivage on va dire
centrale où un camp un consensus
centrale et plus des extrêmes qui
débattent ou d'autres formes de
coalition mais en tout cas que ceux qui
ont des choses à dire les 10 sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle
plutôt que sur certains plateaux de
télévision ou dans la rue dans des
manifestations qu'on a pu voir parce
qu'aujourd'hui la société ce temps il ya
aussi les gilet jaune qui ont été là
pour rappeler que des personnes ne se
sentait pas au plus représentés
aujourd'hui si on veut que ces personnes
qui votent moins qu'ils se sentent moins
représentés au parlement retrouve le
débat politique que la nation mérite non
pas par chaîne de télé interposés mais
au contraire de
à l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale
eh bien la proportionnelle est une
nécessité pour retrouver ce lien entre
les français leurs représentants